ANNOUNCER: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
HERBERT GROSS: Hi, our lecture
today, if we're looking at
this from an analytical point
view, should be called 'Maxima
and Minima'.
And if we're looking at it
from a geometric point of
view, 'High Points
and Low Points'.
And actually, whichever point of
view we're looking at from,
it's a very nice application off
much of the theory that we
have learned up until now.
So without further ado, let's
talk a little bit about what
we mean by high points, low
points, maxima or minima.
Which is, as I say, I've called
the lecture today.
Now, as is always the case, we
usually have to have some sort
of a fundamental result
from which all of our
other results follow.
And in this context what I call
the fundamental theorem
for a study of maxima minima
is the following.
Suppose that 'f of c' is at
least as great as 'f of x' for
all 'x' in a delta neighborhood
of 'c'.
In other words, we have some
open interval with delta
surrounding 'c'.
And then for all 'x' in that
neighborhood, 'f of c' is at
least as great as 'f of x'.
Or equivalently, it might be
that 'f of c' is less than or
equal to 'f of x' for all 'x'
in this neighborhood.
And suppose also, that 'f
prime of c' exists.
Then the theorem says, 'f
prime of c' in this
case, must be 0.
And whereas this can be proven
analytically, again the
analytical proof is motivated
by what's happening
geometrically.
And the geometric demonstration
is particularly
easy to visualize in this
particular case.
Let me run the risk of drawing
this fairly freehand here.
See what we're saying is this.
Suppose you have at the point
(c, 'f of c') on this
particular curve.
Suppose that this particular
curve the derivative exists
and is positive.
See that's the way
I've drawn this.
In other words, notice that in
the neighborhood of the point
'c' here, for example, the
derivative here is positive.
The curve is always rising.
Now, what we're saying over here
is that if you look at
this particular picture, observe
that 'f of c' will not
exceed 'f of x' for all 'x'
in this neighborhood.
In fact, I think you can see
just by looking at this
picture that as 'x' increases,
'f of x' increases.
In other words, in terms of this
picture, if 'x' is less
than 'c', 'f of x' is
less than 'f of c'.
And if 'x' is greater than
'c', 'f of x' is
greater than 'f of c'.
In other words, what we're
saying is if the derivative is
positive, it means that the
curve is always rising.
And hence, the point in the
middle of that neighborhood
cannot be the highest point
in that neighborhood.
Nor, for example, can it
be the lowest point.
In fact, a similar argument
holds if we want to illustrate
that 'f of c' is less than or
equal to 'f of x' in this
particular neighborhood.
And by the way, again, observe
what we're saying.
This is rather crucial
over here.
First of all, we're talking
about a sufficiently small
neighborhood of 'c'.
What I mean by that is
something like this.
And by the way, this could
cause a little bit of a
problem if you're not careful
with your language.
If we drew a picture like this
and you say to somebody, where
are the high-low
points on this?
I think it's quite natural that
the person would say,
well, this is the high point.
I'll call that 'H'.
And this is the low point.
I'll call that 'L'.
And he might tend to forget
about this point here because
even though it's fairly high,
it's not nearly as high as
this point.
What I'd like you to see however
is that our definition
talks about what?
In a neighborhood of
the given point.
You see what we're saying here
is that if we pick a
particular neighborhood,
an appropriately chosen
neighborhood surrounding 'c',
then what is true is that at
the value of 'x' corresponding
to 'c', 'f of c' is the
highest point in a suitable
neighborhood of 'c'.
In other words, if you knew that
for some reason or other,
you had to be working in this
neighborhood here, you could
say, well, in the domain in
which I'm interested in, this
is a high point.
And this is why we talk about
'local' or 'relative' maxima
or minima in addition to
'absolute' maxima and minima.
In fact, you see, this happens
quite frequently in practice.
Suppose you were doing an
experiment and you really
wanted to produce the largest
possible value of 'y'.
Well, you see, utopianaly you
would like to pick 'x' out
here someplace.
But suppose because of some
constraint in the laboratory,
the largest value of 'x'
that you could choose
might be over here.
And then you see what the
equivalent problem would be.
And this is where the domain
of the function has such a
powerful meaning in terms of
practical applications.
What you're saying is look-it ,
if the domain of my function
is limited to this interval
over here, then this
particular point as far
as I'm concerned
is the highest point.
In other words then, notice
that the labelling 'N sub
'delta of c'' indicates that
you're talking locally rather
than globally in a neighborhood
of 'c'.
And this is the important
issue here.
Now, the hardest part about this
particular result as I
see it, is not understanding the
result as much as it is of
reading more into the result
than what's really there.
And so I have a few
cautions for you.
The three commandments
they turn out to be.
The first is, beware
of false converses.
And before you can be beware of
false converses, you have
to know what a converse is.
Roughly speaking, a converse
applies only to an if-then
type of statement.
And you get the converse
of a given statement by
interchanging the clauses that
follow the if and the then.
And the reason you have to
beware is that a true
statement can have
a false converse.
For example, consider the
following true statement.
If a person is listening to me
lecture now, then he is alive.
Hopefully, a true statement.
If we now interchange the
clauses to form the converse
it says if a person is
alive, then he is
listening to me lecture.
A tragically false statement.
But notice the difference
between inverting the clauses
of an if-then statement.
And the idea is this.
Notice that our theorem says if
'f prime' exists, then-- or
if there is a local maximum
or a local minimum, 'f
prime of c' is 0.
It does not say that if 'f prime
of c' is 0 we have a
local maximum or a
local minimum.
Perhaps the easiest
way to see that is
in terms of an example.
That's the nicest thing to show
how a converse is false.
To prove that something is true,
you can't do it just by
showing its true in
certain cases.
But to show that something is
not true, all you have to do
is exhibit one example in which
the result is false.
That's enough to prove that
it can't always be true.
For example, in this particular
diagram, notice
that in the curve 'y' equals
'f of x', which I've drawn
here, the curve at the point
'c' comma 'f of c' has a
horizontal tangent.
In other words, 'f prime
of c' is 0 here.
But notice that in any
neighborhood that surrounds
'c', in any open interval that's
around 'c', notice that
if 'x' is less than 'c', 'f of
x' will be less than 'f of c'.
And if 'x' is greater than 'c',
'f of x' will be greater
than 'f of c'.
In other words, notice that
except for the stationary
value at which we have a
horizontal tangent, the graph
is always rising in any
neighborhood of 'c'.
That's the first point
I want you to see.
The second point says
beware if 'f prime
of c' doesn't exist.
See all our theorem
said is, look it.
If you have a relative high
point, a relative low point,
relative max, or a relative min
at 'x' equal 'c', and if
'f prime of c' exists, then
'f prime of c' is 0.
But who said that 'f prime
of c' has to exist?
Again, let's look in terms
of an example.
If we let 'f of x' equal the
absolute value of 'x', recall
from our previous assignments
and the like that the
derivative of 'f of x',
in this case, does not
exist when 'x' is 0.
In other words, 'f prime
of 0' doesn't exist.
And why is that?
Well, notice that the graph of
'y' equals the absolute value
of 'x' is the straight line
'y' equals 'x' if 'x' is
non-negative and the straight
line 'y' equals 'minus x' if
'x' is negative.
In other words, 'f prime of x'
is 1 if 'x' is positive.
It's minus 1 if 'x'
is negative.
And hence, a jump discontinuity
in the
derivative at 0.
But you see, the
point is this.
If you look at our graph,
do we have a low point
at 'x' equals 0?
In other words, is this the
lowest point in the
neighborhood of 0?
And the answer is yes.
In fact, it's an 'absolute'
low point.
Meaning that no matter where you
go, no point on our graph
can be less or lower than this
particular point here.
But that's irrelevant.
The point is what?
If we looked for a place where
'f prime of c' was 0 in this
example, we wouldn't find one.
That would not mean that there
wasn't a low point.
What happened was what?
The low point snuck in
at a place where the
derivative did not exist.
And again, you have
to be careful.
All I said was what?
Beware of points for which 'f
prime of c' does not exist.
It does not mean that at each
point where 'f prime of c'
does not exist that you're
going to have a
high or a low point.
For example, remember that the
derivative not existing
loosely speaking means what?
That there's a sharp corner
to the curve.
What I'm thinking of is
something like this.
Let's take a curve that's
always rising, say
something like this.
Now, let's suppose we put a
sharp corner in here, but in
such a way that the curve still
continues to always rise.
Say like this.
Now you see, at this particular
value of 'c', 'f
prime of c' doesn't exist.
I think you can see intuitively
what's happening here.
The slope approaches one value
as you approach 'c' from the
left and another value if you
approach 'c' from the right.
Now even know 'f prime of c'
doesn't exist at this point,
notice that this point
is neither a
high nor a low point.
Meaning that all points what?
To the left of this point are
below it and all points to the
right of this point
are above it.
So again, what?
Beware when 'f prime of c'
equals 0, but don't jump to
any false conclusions.
And the third caution is an
extremely important one.
In fact, for the first time
from a practical point of
view, we are going to probably
see analytically what is the
difference between
an open interval
and a closed interval.
Suppose I have the function 'f
of x' equals 'x squared', but
the domain of 'f' is now the
open interval from 2 to 3.
In other words, the inputs of
the 'f' machine are restricted
to all those numbers which
are greater than 2,
but less than 3.
Now, let's take a look here.
Let's first of all, see where
'f prime of x' is 0.
First of all, 'f prime of x' is
'2x' and that equals 0 if
and only if 'x' equals 0.
Now here's where the domain
is very important.
Is 'x' equal 0 in our domain?
The answer is no.
'x' equals 0 is not
in our domain.
Our domain is restricted to be
the open interval from 2 to 3.
Therefore, as far as our
function 'f' is concerned--
and remember, way back in one
of our early, I don't even
think it was a lecture.
It was in our supplementary
notes.
We pointed out that when you
define a function, you need
not only the rule, but you
must specify the domain.
Remember, two functions were
equal not only if they were
the same rule, but they had to
be defined on the same domain.
So f here is defined on
a domain from 2 to 3.
And on that particular domain
of definition there is no
place where the derivative
is 0.
By the same token, since the
derivative is a polynomial and
all polynomials are
differentiable, and all
differentiable functions are
continuous, there certainly
will be no places where 'f prime
of x' doesn't exist.
In other words, 'f prime' exists
for all 'x' in the
domain of 'f'.
In other words, here is a
particular example in which a
particular function on its
domain of definition does not
have any high or low
points on it.
And I'll illustrate that
graphically in a few moments.
I simply wanted to put this on
the board first to put it into
sharp contrast with what we're
going to say next.
If we're not careful, in fact,
the next problem looks exactly
the same as the problem
that we just solved.
Namely, what we want to do now
is investigate the function 'f
of x' equals 'x squared'.
But we want the domain of
'f' now to be what?
The closed interval
from 2 to 3.
In other words, the only
difference between this
problem and the problem that we
just solved is that now we
want the endpoints included.
Now, there's no sense
repeating the
part that we did before.
First of all, will 'f prime of
x' equal 0 in the domain of
definition?
As we saw before, no.
Is 'f prime' nonexistent any
place in the interval?
No, it's differentiable.
It's a smooth polynomial
curve.
Answer is no.
Now, here's where we come to two
very important points that
hopefully, will clarify certain
conventions that were
made in the textbook.
In our section on continuity
there was a little result that
may have seemed a little
bit obscure.
It said what?
That a continuous function
defined on a closed interval
must take on its maximum and
minimum values someplace on
that closed interval.
You see, all we've proven
over here is what?
That if 'f' has a max or min,
what we've proven is what?
It does not occur in the open
interval from 'a' to 'b'.
Well, look it.
If the high and low points have
to occur some place on
the closed interval and they
can't appear, as we've seen,
in the open interval, where
must they occur?
Well, if they can't be inside
and they have to be on the
interval, it must be that they
take place at the endpoints.
Let's go back without referring
back to another board.
Remember we wrote down when
we're talking about high and
low points that we talked about
'x' being in a delta
neighborhood of 'c'.
It meant what?
That you could surround 'c'
by some bandwidth 'delta'.
And notice that our definition
in the textbook of a
neighborhood was always
an open interval.
And the reason that the
definition is given to be open
is that notice that what the
definition now says is what?
You know what's going on
on either side of 'c'.
We know what's going on
either side of 'c'.
Notice that in the case where
you have a closed interval, by
definition of a closed interval
notice that what?
We know what's happening as we
come in on 'a' from the right.
And we know what's happening
to 'b' as we come in on it
from the left.
But allegedly, meaning that
since the function is only
defined on the closed interval
from 'a' to 'b', we don't know
what's happening before 'a',
and we don't know what's
happening before 'b'.
In other words, this is why the
test for 'f prime of c'
equaling 0 applies only to 'c'
being in the interior.
In other words, in
an open interval.
So in other words then, you see
if a function happens to
be continuous on the closed
interval and it doesn't have
any high-low points in the
interior of the interval, then
it must have its high-low
points where?
It must be at the endpoints.
And to show you quite simply
what was going on in this
particular problem, notice
that if we graph 'f of x'
equals 'x squared' and look at
this say, first of all, on the
closed interval from 2 to 3 what
we're saying is look it,
any point in which we look at a
neighborhood that isn't 2 or
3, the curve is rising on
one side of the point.
In other words, the curve is
rising on both sides of the
point, so that if you are to
the left of the point, the
height will be less than the
point you're interested in.
If you're to the right of it,
the height will exceed the
point that you're
interested in.
But notice that at the end
points themselves, you do have
what in this case?
Not a relative high or
low, but actually an
absolute high or low.
In other words, the
point '2 comma 4'.
See, what is the
endpoint here?
One endpoint is 4, the other
endpoint going up on the
y-direction here is 9.
What you're saying is what?
4 is less than 9.
Every value of 'x squared'
between 2 and 3 falls
between 4 and 9.
And what you're saying
is what?
That the lowest point occurs
when 'x' is 2, the highest
point occurs when 'y' is 3.
The interesting point to note is
that if you now look at the
open interval and exclude the
endpoints, you cannot get a
lowest point or a
highest point.
Namely, notice that if you allow
yourself to get as close
to 2 as you want without ever
getting there, it means you
could have done what?
Moved closer to 2.
In other words, if 'x' is
greater than 2, you can pick
another value that's what?
Between 'x' and 2.
There's a space there.
In other words, what you saying
is that no matter how
low you get here, as long as
you're not exactly at 2, you
can find the point
that's lower.
And in the same way as you move
out this way, as you move
closer and closer to this point,
if you exclude this
point itself, no matter where
you stop, you could have
always found the point that
was a little bit higher.
And again, you have
to be where?
When I say check the endpoints
of a closed interval, it does
not mean that the endpoints
will give
you high or low points.
For example, look at the
following curve.
It looks something like this.
It's continuous.
It's defined on the closed
interval from 'a' to 'b'.
Notice that at a we do not
get an absolute maximum.
In fact, what?
All of these points on the curve
are higher than what's
happening here.
Same thing happens, what?
All of these points are lower
than what the height is
corresponding to
'x' equals 'a'.
And in the similar way, this
is what happens at 'b'.
You see, with the endpoints,
obviously since you can't see
what's happening before, this
will be either the highest
point or the lowest point near
here depending on how the
curve is sloped.
But all we're saying is what?
In terms of absolute high
values and absolute low
values, meaning the highest
possible points and the lowest
possible points, we must always
check the endpoints.
But we can't be positive
that the endpoints
are going to be chosen.
In fact, let's summarize.
And I'm going to summarize
again at
the end of the lecture.
But the idea is this.
If 'f of x' is continuous on the
closed interval from 'a'
to 'b'-- and here's
the key word.
To find candidates--
you know the old cliche
about many are
called, but few are chosen.
In this case, few are called
and even fewer are chosen.
Namely, what we're saying
is look it.
When we're looking for
high-low points, the
candidates are what?
Those points for which
the derivative is 0.
We can check those out because
those are possibilities.
Those points for which the
derivative fails to exist.
We can check those out because
they're possibilities.
And the endpoints.
Namely, if the function
is continuous,
we check the endpoints.
By the way, if the function is
not continuous, then there is
no need to check-- well,
let's put it this way.
If you're on an open interval
there's no need to check the
endpoints because there
aren't any.
In other words, notice that
I'm talking about what?
That the function 'f' is not
only continuous, but on a
closed interval.
That's all there is to this.
In other words, these are all
the possible candidates.
Now you see the bigger
question is,
how do you use this?
And I thought that I would make
up a makeshift exercise,
one that's rather easy to
do at the blackboard.
For deeper exercises, for more
quantitative results, we have
several exercises in the
learning exercises.
Several exercises worked out
illustratively in the textbook.
But let's pick a particularly
straightforward example.
Let's suppose that what I want
to do is construct a cylinder.
This is a cross sectional
view of a cylinder.
'x' represents the radius of
the base and 'y' represents
the height.
This is a right circular
cylinder.
I'm given a constraint, namely
I'm told that for some reason
or other, and I don't know why
anybody would ever want to
impose this condition other
than the fact that we want
some condition imposed here
to see what's happening.
I'm told that I want the sum of
the radius of the base and
the altitude to be exactly 30.
In other words, if the radius
of the base is going to be 6
inches, I want the altitude
to be 24 inches.
That's a constraint.
And by the way, I'll come
back to this later also.
Notice how you're almost
begging a related rates
relationship here.
Or an implicit relationship
that 'x' and 'y' are not
independent.
But I've now put a constraint
on here.
At any rate the question is,
how shall I use up my 30
inches, say, if I want to make
the volume of the resulting
cylinder as large as possible?
And notice how we
work this thing.
We say, well, the volume is
equal to 'pi 'x squared' y'.
In this particular case, it's
easy to see explicitly that
'y' is equal to '30 - x'.
It's also easy to see physically
that 'x' must be
more than 0.
You can't have a negative
radius of the base.
It must be less than 30 because
if you used up more
than 30 inches in the radius
of your base, how can the
radius of the base plus the
altitude add up to exactly 30?
Because physically, the
constraint is that the
altitude can't be negative.
It's certainly a
positive value.
So our analytic relationship
is what?
That 'v' equals 'pi 'x squared'
y', which can be
written as 'pi 'x squared'
times '30 - x''.
Which in turn, can be written
as the polynomial '30 pi 'x
squared'' minus 'pi 'x cubed'',
where 'x' is the open
interval or defined on the open
interval from 0 to 30.
Now, how do I proceed?
What was my test
for membership?
I have three ways of
checking out where
high-low points will occur.
Or max-min points in this case,
since notice that this
function does not require a
graph to understand it.
I first check out to see where
the derivative is 0.
Well, the derivative
is simply '60 pi x'
minus '3 pi 'x squared''.
If I set this thing equal to 0,
I find upon factoring that
either 'x' must be 0
or 'x' must be 20.
I can immediately exclude 'x'
equals 0 because notice that
my function 'v' had its domain
of definition on the open
interval from 0 to 30.
'x' equals 0 is not in the open
Consequently, we can rule
this thing out.
And what we discover is
that 'x' equals 20.
So 'x' equals 20 is
the only possible
candidate that we have.
And by the way, since the sum of
'x' and 'y' must be 20, if
'x' equals 20, 'y' must be 10.
So the only candidate that we
have by setting the derivative
equal to 0 is that 'x' should
be 20 and 'y' should be 10.
We do not get any candidates
in the sense of where the
derivative doesn't exist.
Because if you look at '60 pi
x' minus '3 pi 'x squared'',
this certainly exists for
all values of 'x'.
And finally, we have no
endpoints to check.
Because again, our
function 'v' is
defined on an open interval.
By the way, if I tried to draw
this somewhat to scale, a very
interesting result turns up,
which may show the power of
analytical methods versus more
intuitive types of methods.
You see, what we showed
here was what?
Without going into the details,
that to get the
largest volume cylinder,
'x' should be 20.
In other words, the radius of
your base should be 20 and the
altitude should be 10.
Let's take a look at that
drawn roughly to scale.
The radius of the base here is
20 and the altitude is 10.
By the way, that means
that the cross
section will be what?
A rectangle whose height is
10 and whose base is 40.
Now intuitively, I think it's
easy to see that for a
rectangle, for a given perimeter
the largest possible
area rectangle is the one
which is a square.
Well, without even trying to
prove that, let's go to this
thing here.
Instead of using up the 20 and
the 10, let's draw a second
rectangle, or a second cross
section of a cylinder where
the radius is 15 and
the height is 15.
Notice that this still satisfies
the fact that the
sum of the radius and
the altitude are 30.
Now, look at this.
If we compute the area of this
particular rectangle, 40 times
10, it's 400.
On the other hand, the
volume is what?
Pi times 20 squared.
The radius of the
base squared.
Times the height, which is 10.
And that yields the result
of 4,000 pi.
On the other hand, if we look
at our second rectangle, its
area is 450.
But its volume is what?
It's pi times 15 squared times
15, which is 3,375 pi.
The interesting result
here is what?
The area of this rectangle
is greater than the
area of this rectangle.
In fact, the area of the second
rectangle is 450.
The area of the first rectangle
is only 400.
But notice that when you revolve
this thing to form the
cylinder, the smaller cross
sectional area generates the
larger volume.
And the reason, of course, for
that is that the relationship
in our variables
was not linear.
In other words notice that
when 'x' is large, a
relatively small change in
'x' produces a large
change in 'x squared'.
In other words, a relatively
small value in 'x' can offset
a relatively large value
or increase in 'y'.
And this is kind of interesting
because try to
figure out intuitively how you
would figure out where these
stop compensating
for one another?
Where does it turn out that
finally you've taken so much
away from 'x' that even though
you square it, it can't
compensate the change in 'y'?
How would you intuitively pick
off where the high-low points
occur in a problem like this?
And all I want you to see is
again, the beautiful gentle
balance between intuitive
calculus
and rigorous calculus.
That we don't throw away
our intuition.
But notice how, in many cases,
where our intuition fails us,
the analytic recipes
come to our rescue.
But enough said about that, let
me now again, highlight
the difference or the
relationship between functions
and graphs.
Namely, in all of this
discussion that we've done on
this particular board, we're
talking about what?
'v' being a function of 'x'.
We do not have to visualize
this thing pictorially.
But if we wish, what we can say
is let's graph 'v' as a
function of 'x'.
And you see, going back to the
material of last time.
And notice, you see how
interrelated these things are.
Notice how curve plotting
ties in very nicely with
derivatives and the like.
All we're saying is what?
Given this relationship, which
is how 'v' is related to 'x',
we can form the first
derivative, we can form the
second derivative, we can look
to see where the first
derivative is 0, we can look
to see where the second
derivative is 0.
I leave these details to you
because after the homework
assignment you did last time
these should be fairly trivial
exercises to do.
But the idea is if you now
utilize all of this
information, you find that if
you plot 'v' verses 'x', you
get a graph something
like this.
By the way, again notice that we
were not talking about just
'v' being a function of 'x'.
The domain of 'v' was restricted
to be the open
interval from 0 to 30, and this
is a very crucial thing
to keep in mind.
You can get into a whole bunch
of trouble if you start
looking to see what
happens out here.
For example, you say, hey, this
curve is always going to
keep going up.
Won't this be greater than this
maximum value over here
eventually?
The answer is yes, it will be.
But what does it mean to say
that 'x' is negative?
'x' was the radius
of our base.
So in other words,
what we should
really say here is what?
That the function that we're
talking about is not this
whole curve.
Yikes, that wasn't a very
good job of drawing.
But rather what?
Just this portion of the curve
defined on the open interval
from 0 to 30.
By the way, let me point
out something else.
You recall in an earlier
lecture we talked about
related rates.
We had an assignment with other
lecture where you've
solved some problems using
related rates.
Let me show you how related
rates play a very important
computational role in dealing
with max-min problems.
In this particular problem, we
had that 'v' equals 'pi 'x
squared' y', where 'y' happened
to be a particular
function of 'x'.
In fact, implicitly it was given
by the fact that 'x + y'
happened to equal 30.
Now let's keep track
of something here.
In this particular problem,
notice that it was very easy
to change this implicit
relationship
to an explicit one.
It was also easy once you
expressed 'y' explicitly in
terms of 'x' that when you
wanted to substitute into
here, it was a very easy
computational job to carry out
the operations.
But suppose there happened to be
cube roots in here, or all
sorts of nasty things, whatever
they might be.
And suppose instead of 'x + y'
equals 30, you had our old
friend something like 'x to the
eighth' plus ''x to the
sixth' 'y squared'' plus 'y
to the sixth' equals 3.
How would you solve for
'y' explicitly in
terms of 'x' there?
And the point that I'd like
you to see is that we can
solve this problem very nicely
without having to resort to
explicitly replacing 'y'
as a function of 'x'.
Namely, implicitly assuming that
'y' is a differentiable
function of 'x', we
can differentiate
this thing as a product.
'dv dx' will be what?
The derivative of the first
factor, which is '2 pi x',
times the second.
Plus the first factor, which is
'pi 'x squared', times the
derivative of 'y' with
respect to 'x'.
So that's 'dv dx'.
On the other hand, from this
relationship here, we can
conclude by differentiating
implicitly that '1
+ 'dy dx'' is 0.
And therefore, 'dy
dx' is minus 1.
And putting that value for 'dy
dx' in here, we wind up with
this explicit relationship.
And we can now see that 'dv dx'
is 0 if and only if just
by solving this thing,
setting it equal to
0, 'x' equals '2y'.
By the way, that's exactly what
happened in our problem.
You'll notice that 'x' turned
out to be 20 and 'y' turned
out to be 10.
You see again, 'x' and
'y' are related.
You can say, gee, couldn't
'x' be 60 and 'y' be 30?
Answer, no.
Because the constraint is
that 'x + y' must be 30.
Well, look it.
I don't want us to get too
wrapped up on the idea of
computational differences now.
What I do want to do is review
our basic result.
And in fact, let me
come over here.
I hope this doesn't spoil you.
I'd like to come back
to the board.
And actually, since I've got
this all written down, let's
close on this particular
result again.
To find the high-low points of
a function 'f of x', we first
of all, check out when 'f
prime of c' is 0 for
candidates.
We check out where 'f prime
of c' fails to exist.
And if it's a closed interval,
we check the endpoints.
This is the mechanism behind
what we're doing from that
point on, as the cliche goes,
it's all engineering's baby.
It's all computational
know how.
At any rate, I think this is
enough in terms of emphasizing
the points that we
wanted to make.
And so until next
time, goodbye.
ANNOUNCER: Funding for the
publication of this video was
provided by the Gabriella and
Paul Rosenbaum Foundation.
Help OCW continue to provide
free and open access to MIT
courses by making a donation
at ocw.mit.edu/donate.